so now i only write stories that wake me
up in the middle of the night and make
me go grab my laptop if it doesn't make
me do that i don't write it
can you take us all the way through your
writing process
um it's changed a lot
before i think my writing process was
more
i had an idea and then
i wanted to
take a really good look at the two main
characters and then branch off from
there
with and i would always write like
random
scenes like these are the must
you know have scenes in the script
because that's what ultimately made me
think about the the
the story
i carried that with me for a while
but now
it's not so much that and it's because
i've i've made enough films where i know
what goes into making one and just
starting at the writing standpoint
so now i only write stories that wake me
up in the middle of the night and make
me go grab my laptop if it doesn't make
me do that i don't write it
if there's something that happens and
i'm like you know what that's it i i
gotta sit down i gotta nail this
and the reason is because you know as
we've spoken about before that passion
if
if what you
have in here isn't
it it doesn't wake you up in the middle
of the night with for this project
then i don't know how possible it is
like you're gonna have to fight so hard
to make it to the end
so for me it starts with
does this thing wake me up in the middle
of the night is this the only thing i
can think about right now
and if it is the only thing i can think
about what am i thinking about right now
why do i want to write this what is it
saying about me and i start with that
and then what i do
is ultimately
something is going on around me that's
making me feel this way and oftentimes
it's music
so then that song is on repeat repeat
repeat repeat i'm writing a story right
now called uh moon and the stars
and
it's a story about love but not romantic
love i mean there's romantic love in it
but it's it's more about the real
concept of love like when you really
love someone what you're willing to do
for them what does it really mean for
you to really love someone and
uh believe it or not
the
i can't get this story out of my head
and i'm already we've already set it up
to start production in 2022.
the song that i have on repeat is what
is a guy's name
weekend
and his song save your tears
i don't know if you've heard that song
but i just have it on repeat and i just
write and i write and i write i'm just
so obsessed with the story i'm so
obsessed with the character's journey
and
at every time i stop because i always
say you know find the perfect scene and
stop
and then when i stop i go back and i
think about all the technical stuff you
know and i start to make notes for
myself okay when you go back to rewrite
make sure you think about this and think
about this and think about this
and then when i sit down the next day to
write it that song goes on and by the
way i don't know if this is a thing for
every song but on youtube you can search
the song and
loop and then it'll come up with
somebody who's made like a two-hour loop
of the same song over and over and over
and i just hit play and i just
and i just and i know what the objective
is for every scene
so i sit down i'm looking through my
notes i'm like okay this is my objective
for today i need to do this for these
previous scenes and then the new scenes
have to be about this
it has to be a point to every scene i
can't just sit down like i did before
and just write a scene and hopefully
some way find some sort of connect you
know some kind of connective tissue for
the rest of the story i have to know the
point of the scene and who's making the
point and why is this person the best
person to make this point
or why is this event the event that
needs to happen now
you know and i that's how i kind of
structure each scene
but i go back and make sure it fits the
story as a whole and i just do that all
the way through
when you say that you you what if it
wakes you up in the middle of the night
are you already up for something else
and then you're like you know what this
one part i've just got to write this
down or how does that work if let's say
it's two in the morning on a tuesday
and you just happen to wake up
what's your process are you going to a
laptop
it all depends it all depends uh
if i am trying to
not wake up
the cat or my wife you know then it's
going to be going into the into the
living room where you know my office is
and you know sitting down at the
computer and just you know but then
there'll be times where maybe i get hit
with inspiration at six a.m six a.m and
the sun's probably starting to come up
it's okay if i grab the laptop and
you know from the bed you know so i'll
do it that way but but usually i feel
something and i have to get up and i
have to write and i have to complete
this script
you know and it happens
it only happens when now because
i think i've
i've allowed myself to
surrender to whatever
[Music]
that that thing is inside you that
intuition it tells you now as a time
i think that it's
something someone said a while back
where you know writing is a profession
and you have to sit down at the keyboard
at a certain time and then you get up
from that computer at a certain time
because it's your job to write it's your
career
and you're professional
that's okay i i get that i get that but
if you are a person who you have
multiple films in various stages of
production
maybe nine to five isn't something i can
do because i'm still editing this one
i'm still handling the promotional stuff
for this one i'm doing interviews over
here for that one
i can't just sit at a computer from nine
to five right
so i write when the inspiration hits me
and oftentimes it is in the middle of
the night it's it's in that moment where
you
you kind of wake up or you're about to
go to sleep that little
that little area i don't know what it is
about that time but it's like ah
there it is and then you just
and you punch you know you sit there and
you punch the keypad until you get it
out of your system you purge out of your
system and you go back and you you read
it and you make sure you got everything
okay i get everything okay cool let me
write my notes and that's just my notes
for what to do when i come back to it
and how does it tie back into the rest
of the story just making sure that it
stays fresh because when you get that
feeling
and you put it on paper you sometimes
forget
certain details
so you make sure i make sure i want to
write it down and then i go back
but yeah i believe that you you have to
surrender to that
that urge
that desire to get up right now
because you you you you feel that this
needs to be on the page at this moment
i don't believe that's something you can
force my best writing has been when i
felt that urge
are you sensitive to the moon
i don't know oh okay because you used
it's called moon and stars or whatever
oh it's moon m-u-n-e and stars
s-t-a-r-r-s okay and uh
it's it's really affecting you yeah no
no no it's funny it's it's uh it's a
story that when i describe it people go
well where's the love story but
it's it's a story about this um
um
this child she's 66 years old
six-year-old prodigy from beijing
and she's
taken through a portal
by this guy named egun and the order of
fanu
and they take her to a place where
uh
love wilts and hope goes to die
and
they take her here and then the story
picks up in this day and age and
there's a guy who's going through a
breakup and he's trying desperately to
get back with his fiance
and
he's been having his vision since he was
a kid of you know
various
catastrophes and this one girl is always
in his dreams and
one day
when he's
just at his bottom
the portal opens up and she comes
through
and she tells him that he's the only
like the ego in the order for new are
coming to basically destroy life as we
know it and you are the only hope
and
the guy who's had no desire to do
anything in his life other than be with
this woman over here
um now has a new mission in life
and ultimately
the woman that he is in love with who
just doesn't want to be with him right
now
she's also enlisted to help him in this
fight to save the universe
and
throughout all of it what he has to
learn
is what what is love truly because love
he thought was showing someone how much
you want to be with them so they'll want
to be with you
but truly it's it's having enough
love for this person to only want the
best for them even if the best for them
isn't you
you know
that's all you want is you want to see
the best for this person and that's the
lesson that he's trying to learn
throughout this movie and that's
ultimately the lesson that helps him
to be successful at saving the world in
the universe
wow but in all of that that just came
from
i don't know what it was something
happened and it just made me evaluate
love and what we think of it as as
people even healthy people like what we
think about love and i was just like man
so many people have it so backwards
so backwards
they or they love a person because of
how the person makes them feel
and it's like that's not love that's
you know it's something
but but it ain't love
um
and that's that's what really wakes me
up is
you know whenever i find some other
example of it and i'm like oh
why isn't that in the script
and then it's like oh and then this
person does this and this event happens
and i'm just constantly jumping up in
the middle of the night or early morning
and plugging in more pages
and
it's all coming from a place of
of uh passion but also truth and and
honesty which i believe truth and
honesty are two very different things
but um
you know it's coming from a place of
truth in a place of honesty and
and uh building this story and those are
the stories that i'm trying to tell now
versus how i used to tell stories i used
to tell stories it was very stream of
consciousness and it was whatever it was
supposed to be and then it was done and
now i put more thought into making sure
the stories are just honest they're
coming from an honest place even if you
don't agree
with the message even if you don't agree
with the characters it's coming from a
place of honesty
yeah i was wondering what what is the
difference between writing honesty and
writing truth in your screenplay um i
think truth is a fact honesty is the
feeling
i think honesty is your intent
okay if you i met many people who are
super honest but their facts are so
screwed up that is not the truth that is
not what happened
but you can tell a person truth and not
be honest also you can tell facts and
omit certain things that don't fit your
narrative and that's being dishonest yet
you're still being truthful
okay so
which would you rather have in a story
truth or honesty
honesty
i think
i think honesty inner story is is better
than the truth
but i i aspire to have both
you